joining us now Mike Freeman of bleacher
report look I saw you tweet yesterday
Mike so I kind of know what you want but
is this truly the team that you want to
see for hard knocks is it truly the
Raiders I want you guys the first as
well queue up their Raiders really fun
interesting team all of a sudden where
you have Antonio Brown and then you have
the guy who knocked Antonio Brown out
which is crazy Gruden is always an
interesting guy to watch I've been sort
of stunned at how Mayock has been able
to come in there I mean just it was
always a fun guy to watch a really
knowledgeable guys you knew he knew his
stuff but going to that franchise and
working with Gruden who is God has
really set in his ways and I'm not
saying Gruden didn't want to do any of
this of course it did
but these moves strike me as a very sort
of very solid football moves that are
building a foundation that are looking
forward that are really to me a lot of
them are smart moves
whereas when Gruden was kind of running
this show they see things seem more
chaotic and it seems like Naoki has
brought a sense of solidarity a solid
footing to the franchise they're not all
there the risky move some of them I mean
bring it perfect in is risky but they
are I think some of these things are
really really smart so there's not even
number two three four five on this
automatically well there was a report
yesterday the analytics company said
that the Raiders move of trading Khalil
Mak last year was the move of the year
and what some of the moves the Raiders
have made this offseason whether it's by
trade or free agency you start to see
sort of the foundation being built and
now you see the vision in front of you
have we finally gotten past the trade of
Khalil Mack
last year now see where the Raiders can
be moving forward with these first-round
draft choices that's a great question
and the answer is a little complicated I
don't know if you ever get past trading
a guy who would go to Chicago I mean he
was good in oh right but he goes to
Chicago and it's just like out of this
world
so do you ever get past the guys trading
a guy like that I don't know it's but a
lot of the answer depends on what
happens in with some of these future
picks what they do with them how well
they dress I mean I've been really
impressed with some of the things
they've done so far so it sort of bodes
well that they'll be able to draft well
but I get a real getting rid of Kahlil
Mac was one of I thought one of the
craziest moves and dumbest moves I've
ever seen and but if they can turn it
around and get somehow get some kind of
franchise quarterback or get more
players they're not going to get a
Khalil Mack is so unique and special but
they can use these picks to keep
building their foundation and I never
thought in a million years they'd go out
get Antonio Brown right so they're doing
things that are to me I mean getting rid
of Khalil Mack was not to me not smart
but they're doing they're making up for
it in a lot of different ways and and
and to me some really smart way you know
the when you look at just the the
landscape of the NFL right now it's been
the big trades right it's been you know
teams I feel like okay we can contend
and I state I start that by saying the
Browns last year go seven eight and one
and everybody was like ready to throw a
parade and then this year they make the
big trip now you know for a guy like
Odell Beckham jr. obviously Baker
Mayfield going into his second season
but in reading your column while on
bleacher report I think we're we aren't
talking enough about the head coach
without the prior experience not just as
a head coach Mike but even as an
offensive coordinator he didn't have the
experience and now you're asking him to
kind of lead these men like how
difficult a job does Freddie kitchens
have in front of them well you you
played in the league you've been in at
the locker room right you know what it's
like
it's a place
very strong personalities some stronger
than others some in some locker rooms
more stronger than others but I think
what we're seeing with the Browns is
that's going to be there's a lot of
personalities in there the two primary
being the quarterback in and Beckham so
how does the guy go in and do that it
there's not a long history of very young
or very inexperienced rather guys going
in a locker room where there's a lot of
strong personalities and immediately
succeeding that you may have to see you
have they have to be just be patient
with him for a little bit and and allow
him to get its footing and get the
respect of those players and I know
those people say you just do what the
coach says that's not how the NFL works
anymore right it's in the 1950s you have
to really get the players to buy in and
the players need to believe in you I
mean you live this you know this you
can't just walk in a locker room anymore
and in 2019 and say do what I say
they gotta believe in you you have to
convince them that's the way the sports
world is now and this is going to be the
challenge for him he doesn't have a
track record to fall back on he's not
Sean Payton going in there he's not Bill
Belichick going in there he's a guy that
I think the offense they really like him
Mayfield likes him but he now has to
work with the whole team and that's
going to be very tricky for a guy with
with very little experience but they
they could end up being and I I know
it's crazy Zack you don't believe oh say
my mouth Super Bowl contender I can't
even I almost passed out when I say that
I mean it's it's true though they are
loaded and that is gonna be his
challenge is not just getting in the
buy-in but getting all that talent to
work together and they're gonna have
more talent to the draft so it's gonna
be they're gonna be really fun to watch
we're talking with bleacher report
columnist Mike Freeman joining the Rich
Eisen show Kirk Morrison fill it in for
Rich but what about the saga or the soap
opera the reality series of the
Pittsburgh Steelers I mean it's getting
the comments of Le'Veon Bell
just recently talking about you know the
organization wants to win but Ben
Roethlisberger wants to win his way we
knew there was drama within the
organization in terms of some players
and the way that Ben Roethlisberger is
leading how do you see this team the
Pittsburgh Steelers kind of overcoming
all this these shadows and out of some
of the players who have now left the
locker room how do we look at the
Steelers review them now this is a this
is one of the big stories entering into
next year the off season next year is
you know Antonio Brown isn't there to
blame things on anymore
Le'Veon Bell isn't there to blame things
on anymore this is now officially
without question Roethlisberger's team
so how will this go and it's going to be
interesting because you you Antonio
Brown was a convenient foil for a lot of
people I'm not saying I agree with
everything you did I didn't but I always
thought the criticism of him was was was
way too harsh
same with Le'Veon Bell well they're not
they're gone now and I I'm interested to
see what happens when a team loses that
kind of talent
I mean Antonio Brown is the best wide
receiver in football
Le'Veon Bell to me was the best running
back in football that is a talent to
lose and essentially one or two years I
mean what how does the team recover from
that and Ben isn't that's not like Ben
Roethlisberger is 23 so this is going to
be really interesting to watch and well
how would you do some issues to react to
not living off of Antonio Brown being
double-teamed we know Connor had a good
year but he will he be able to be
healthy the whole year will you be able
to stay healthy little and and do come
close to levy on bail maybe he can maybe
can't book and what will then look like
these there is a lot of questions in
Pittsburgh and I I think the fans are
going to be surprised to see or maybe
not maybe they won't be but
a lot of people who just don't get that
that kind of talent doesn't just come
along every year you don't get in Tonio
brown's every year or levy on bells
old-time to turn to yard losses in 222
yard games right that is a hard thing to
find in the league and they just lost
two of those guys so let's see how that
goes Bleacher Report's Mike Freeman join
the program here Rich Eisen Kirk
Morrison filling in for rich to think
about this though Mike I mother kind of
throw you for a loop here the last
quarterback to beat the Steelers in the
playoffs was who ooh
last quarterback to deep steals in the
playoffs yeah I'm not sure who it was
Blake bortles in the divisional round we
forget how soon we forget that Blake
bortles beat the Pittsburgh Steelers in
the last playoff appearance and now we
fast forward to now Blake bortles is now
the backup to jerk golf in Los Angeles I
was reading your piece a little bit
earlier and it's one thing people like
why why Blake bortles why would you sign
him but when you think about it it isn't
this the right move for a guy like Blake
bortles it's perfect to me I mean I know
that your initial reaction you just
that's a great point to bring up Blake
bortles was he was seen as pretty good
by the league and he just completely
fell off a cliff but he was seen as
pretty good and he's now going to a
situation where there's no pressure on
him and you can see what McVeigh did
with Jarrod Golf was pretty remarkable I
know jerk off did not have a good Super
Bowl I get that right but all year your
golf is really good and a lot of that is
because of obviously him but also
because of Sonic Bay so maybe McVeigh
can do the same thing with bortles
I mean born of the times has looked so
bad last year but he can turn it around
and there's no pressure on him he's now
the backup and he's working with some
really good offensive talent so it's not
it's a pretty I think it's a pretty good
move by the round
initially I was like this is crazy but
then when you talk to people around the
league about it I thought it was pretty
smart and I think it's a pretty good
move too you know Mike I do want to get
your thoughts on what the New York
Giants are doing because it's are they
rebuilding are they not are they eyeing
a quarterback are they not they just
trade away Odell Beckham jr. if you said
Antonio Brown is number one I don't know
where we put kind of Odell Beckham is
e23 I know he's top five but you trade
it now traded that away if you're the
New York Giants as we try to look at the
vision of where this team is going what
do they need to do upcoming in this
draft is it drafting a quarterback in
the with the pick that they have early
on at six or do they sit back and wait
another year under Eli Manning what
gives here it's a great question and I
think a lot of people have no clue the
Giants are doing I mean it the moves are
making make no sense they get rid of
Odell Beckham for what seems to be just
a just purely out of they think he's a
headache I don't think he really was
right but they think he was so you get
rid of him and you're bringing into
older receiver in Golden Tate who I like
a lot right but that doesn't make sense
you keep a quarterback who was clearly
on the downside he brought you to Super
Bowls he's had a really good career but
he's not the same guy
he's one of he's going downhill pretty
fast now if they go in the draft and
draft a quarterback some of that can
make sense but they're doing things that
to me really smack of just getting rid
of guys you they just who don't think
their personalities will mesh instead of
trying to figure out ways to make it
work
I don't think Odell Beckham was that
much of a headache I mean he kicked a
net punched a wall right who cares
it's not like he's out getting arrested
not doing crazy stuff off the field like
he went on a boat one time so it's to me
I always thought a lot of that was
overblown I thought the Giants
completely overreacted with him and it
got rid of I mean if he's not two or
three he's definitely top five I think
he's more like two or three that's her
second third best receiver Lee
and they got rid of them I don't
understand when teams it just doesn't
make sense to me when teams get rid of
these star elite players and don't get
as much in return and it makes no sense
to me I understand the Giants are doing
but if they get it
quarterback a good quarterback it can
help salvage at least some of this to me
we're speaking with bleacher report
columnist Mike Freeman here on the Rich
Eisen show Kirk Morrison filling in for
rich but last question for you Mike
because this one more of a sensitive
topic in terms of Tyree keel and the
Kansas City Chiefs you know right now
the investigation is kind of underway on
what's you know going on are alleged to
have happened with Tyree keel if you're
the Kansas City Chiefs and everybody's
kind of putting them as a Super Bowl
favorite in terms of getting to the game
and possibly winning if you have to lose
out on Tyree keel for you know I don't
know if six games eight games if
anything does come out of that how do
you view this team now without probably
one of the best weapons in the NFL
well I'm it's it's a really as you said
it's a really crazy sensitive topic
right and I hate to break it down along
football lines was something that was
potentially so devastating but this is
what we do for a living this is a sport
we cover and what we talk about I think
if there's some type of punishment for
Hill I it would it would change the
dynamic there a little bit because he
was is was whatever we're gonna say he
he is a he a really remarkably talented
player who can transform a game in an
instant because of his speed and that
made that offense very very scary and
without him it's still good right I mean
that quarterback is incredibly talented
but if they do end up losing him if that
does end up happening it takes away an
element of for them that was really that
that made defenses really nervous
because he could on any single play at
any time just just
score he was he's that fast he's that
good but this is gonna this whole case
is gonna be interesting to watch it just
does not sound good
yeah from reading it from seeing from
afar we don't know what happened
it may not maybe he may not have done
anything but you you there was an
element there's some truth to saying
that do you give the guy the benefit of
doubt after what he was accused of from
previous incidents so this is gonna be
very very interesting to watch another
one of those stories are watching elf
season at which as you know the NFL
offseason never ends the season goes
forever it's going to next year my man
it's gonna start with the Raiders hard
knock can we get the Raiders music again
Mike Dale to phones thinking about the
NC double-a tournament yeah see that's
what he's worried about trying to pick
out his brackets hey Mike Freeman
bleacher report column is appreciate the
time as always my man appreciate it love
what you do love what you do custom
alright thanks Mike Mike Freeman
bleacher report the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience